hello there reject nation we are going
to watch today the final trailer or
maybe not the final one but some people
are saying it's the final one for marvel
studios thor love and thunder we are
literally running pretty late we got to
get ready as we are going to watch this
movie at the premiere in about 45
minutes so this is going to be a rush
edit subscribe and click that
notification bell for whenever our
review for the movie lifts embargoes in
through three weeks or something also
leave it leave a bloody like would you
what
marx is not god
guy richie's hammer wielder yes let's
get to it we just reacted to three clips
also that will be going up probably
tomorrow or saturday whenever i got time
to edit that so yeah don't be thinking
we're reacting to stuff when uh we've
already watched the movies we're just
saying we shot it in advance it'll be
getting uploaded because i know those
comments will come in anyway all right
let's get to it
[Music]
there's the maniac who seeks to end us
all
and putting together the greatest team
ever are you packed
oh she's packed
celestia
oh dang
[Music]
[Music]
screaming goats
oh my god they're gonna be seen stealers
get those memes
you said this would be a relaxing
holiday
actually did that human handshake
to the asgardian shake
into the snake
that you cannot trust
really dragging this out let's finish
the classic asgardian high one
[Music]
oh my goodness
that was fantastic these are so
delightful that was really fun trailer
it's the first time it's being the goats
apparently i thought it might have been
something in the film where he's like
being re-rekindled with them or reunited
with them i mean he's being reunited
with him i've missed you from past
adventures we've never seen on screen
yeah i thought that's what it might be
but i like the fact that he's gonna be
forming a new relationship with them and
then
seeing how like the hijinks will go with
them i imagine it'll be one of those
things where they're a bit frustrating a
little bit loud obnoxious annoying at
first but then they become like heroes i
hope they have like a heroic moment and
i'm hoping not one of them goats dies by
the end of the film as that would be
very very very upsetting not about that
no but i think also too for you know
this movie still embracing that kind of
80s quality to have like the van damme
split kick in there
perfect homage if you guys haven't seen
john claw van damme films do yourself a
favor why are you wasting your life
watch some jean-claude van damme films
would you yeah that's your homework from
this video yeah but yeah i know i mean
this looks this movie is looks super fun
from the get-go and i love that with all
these clips and now this trailer i'm
really curious what the combination of
tones is gonna be like because obviously
taika is a master of comedy but i know
some people didn't love that thor
ragnarok was such an overt comedy and it
feels like while there's tons and tons
of really fun and amusing stuff i feel
like there's some real darkness creeping
under the surface that's gonna maybe
surprise us all with gore the god
butcher and also we saw celestials here
so i'm like how how much butchering of
how far are we gonna go introducing
goran seeing that level of his power
because so much of phase four has been
about introducing all the powers that be
and all the different gods aside from
the ones we're already aware of and so
yeah there's something about this where
i feel like they're leading with the fun
but they might surprise us with some
more heavy and more slightly harrowing
approaches to this true darkness yeah i
mean i'm kind of like the celestials
thing i can imagine being
a massive deal it should be it maybe
maybe it ought to be a big deal but to
me it looks like it's just played for
humorous moments
maybe it'll tie in a little bit later
like it's overstood out to me that we've
been to a few marvel premieres by this
point
and you know the only one we've seen
taika ytd actually attend was eternals
and he seemed very focused on the film
when he was watching it so to see that
celestials are being brought into here
now considering that was the movie where
they were the most prominent focus uh of
the filming i i feel like it's gotta be
a bigger deal but i could also just see
it being a joke just a little quick
thing where olympus where they escape
after the fight and there were
celestials watching and maybe the
celestials make some jokes they bring
some humor they're the celestials and
then they just zip off you know i mean i
don't know i'm not sure how it'll be i
feel like if there's one person who
could make humor out of something that
you wouldn't think would be humorous
taika ytd could be the one to pull it
off i know some people don't like that
about taiko ytd but i think taika can
pull it off i'm not sure i'm not sure if
to make a big deal about it now or to go
down like a bunch of theory rabbit holes
yeah it feels like phase four has almost
been the sort of antithetical to going
down the theory rabbit hole it's more
just like no this thing just showed up
and it's there and we're gonna use it
later yeah yeah yeah um but as it stands
i did think that this was a really fun
trailer and i do get the sense that one
of our main characters is going to die
i'm so worried
i think like valkyrie definitely has the
potential to die especially because they
keep teasing that fight with gore the
god butcher that she has and acting like
this is the best day of her life and
then what better way for her to go down
than a valkyrie fighting for her honor
for the people she loves because it also
looks like that's part of the same fight
that thor eventually has with gore and
that's in that same scene but we don't
know we don't see um you know thor and
valkyrie fighting nick at least i don't
recall them seeing them fight side by
side with each other against thor i mean
against gore like a two-on-one fight so
i i feel like valkyrie could be killed
off which would definitely raise the
stakes of the situation and you know
provide more of an impact you know um
but i really don't know yeah it feels
like she would be the most likely out of
like the main trio of characters yeah i
don't know i mean they could go really
bold but i don't think they would ever
kill off chris hemsworth's thor no no i
think they would just let him depart for
a while if that was the case so yeah i
mean i would hate to see valkyrie go but
if they give her a good moment to go out
on you know let's do it
all right guys we'll thor love it
thunder uh keep a lookout for whenever
those movie clip reactions go up we
might do a just saw thor i think that's
a little so
that might go up first before those
clips go out which would be kind of a
weird upload process but whatever we
already filmed this we're gonna we're
gonna do it
um but yeah subscribe click that bell
leave a like uh last but not least let's
sense with a patreon
maria hammond maria is uh
one of the most special people in the
world i've ever gotta know she's gifted
us with some of
the most rewarding gifts ever things
that we actually use and wear
constantly frequently and um you wish me
a happy belated birthday on twitter but
uh maria it was my birthday but it was
john's birthday you said also make sure
to sell john happy belated birthday so
i'm here to pass the message along thank
you well and then that's good because
that makes good on last year's birthday
for you and technically then she also
early wished you a happy birthday for
this year so maria is covering all the
bases with generosity you don't need to
send us anything else
you've covered it for this year with the
belated and early birthday wishes well
maria in a lot of ways you are like a
mighty thor for our channel you really
are you are the strong female protector
of the channel and of our name and you
always defend us so thank you so much
for uh being the sweetheart that you are
you're uh you're one of a kind
and i'm really happy to know your soul
thank you
[Music]